with pickaxes shovels and even their
bare hands
rescue workers and volunteers work to
save people trapped in the mud
in India's Himalayan region heavy rains
brought floods which then triggered
landslides washing Away Homes
range in the last 24 hours have wreaked
havoc on Himachal Pradesh in the temple
near Shimla we have identified five
bodies around 20 to 22 people are still
missing we are trying everything to save
the lives of those buried
climate change is increasingly being
blamed for extreme and devastating
weather events
worshipers were on a pilgrimage to one
of the holiest sites for Hindus in the
state capital Shimla when disaster
struck
yeah
cloudburst occur during which the
railway track and road collapsed it's
expected that beneath this there are 20
to 25 people still trapped this is the
Shiva Temple which is 150 years old
there's been a lot of damage to lives
and property foreign
fall and the flooding it triggered has
damaged roads buildings and forced the
closure of schools with shelters being
set up for the displaced
the situation is bad there are
continuous floods and the rivers are
overflowing there are flash floods
Villages are being flooded and people's
homes have been affected
India's meteorological department has
issued a red alert for both Himachal
Pradesh and uttarakhan states with more
rain forecast for the start of the week
Michael Apple Al Jazeera
foreign